comme ça on dirait presque une lycéenne
en vacances à l'ermitage manon a m'a
coûté à rendez-vous cet après-midi avec
nawel et jesse deux des acteurs de son
premier film elle passe son bac lui est
déjà comédien depuis quelques années
[Musique]
dans la petite sirène n'a où elle joue
le rôle d'une adolescente décédée qui
revient à la vie pour trois jours il me
regardait comme ça je pensais que
j'avais jamais trop loin
le film raconte le week end qu'elle va
passer avec ses trois meilleurs amis
sans les routes du département
je mets en quoi
manon et ses deux acteurs se sont donnés
rendez-vous seront des lieux du tournage
la boutique carpaye
dans le film la petite bande faisait
escale ici pour se ravitailler avant de
partir en week-end
là il y avait des ennemis
[Musique]
j'étais là et je devais apprendre
beaucoup
et forcément ça faisait une file et j'en
ai fait tomber quelques heures souvent
et c'était une réalisatrice comment elle
dure manon jamais ça c est de faire don
quand il le faut mais non elle a ses
phrases par la junte à ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe là tu sais que tu
rates ton truc c'est que ce n'était pas
bien et aujourd'hui même quand il décide
de boire un verre pour fêter la sortie
de leur film
c'était la limonade qu'il travaillera
pas ingrate pas
quel enfant
robin
à toi manon sort alors de son sac
quelques photos du tour je connais mais
n'a pas bossé moi rester là c'est ici
j'étais très
fazi la jeune réalisatrice se rappelle
aussi cette scène de noyade
tourné par nawel dans le froid du mois
d'août
je pense que c'était la séquence de ta
vie dans toute sa carrière tout c'est
vraiment la scène que j'ai préféré
tourner c'est vrai oui c'était vraiment
trop génial d'orange il y avait la
caméra et tous qui était juste à côté de
moi y'a bouge en même temps qu'eux mais
c'était trop bien non quand on pose dans
l'eau il faisait pas du tout
c'est la plus belle photo c'est là que
j'ai appris ça c'est la plus belle photo
en tentant de répéter la chanson et
[Musique]
ce soir c'est à la cité des arts de
saint denis que la petite sirène sera
projeté pour la première fois comme pour
boucler la boucle
car c'est ici que tout a commencé pour
manon amacouty après trois années
d'école de cinéma à paris elle fait
partie en 2017 de la première sélection
des talents la cour un dispositif créé
pour accompagner les jeunes cinéastes
réunionnais auquel deux ans plus tard
est de retour pour une rencontre avec la
nouvelle promotion des talents la cour
ils sont dix dans le rond et chacun rêve
de réaliser son premier film pour le
moment leur projet s'étale sur les murs
en petits bouts de papier et tous
voudraient évidemment connaître le
secret de manon
t
non plus mais non c'était pas dur elle
raconte d'abord à quel point elle a été
émerveillé de pouvoir travailler comme
une vraie réalisatrice avec une vraie
équipe autour d'elle quand on est là en
face des post it on s'imagine pas en
fait que ça va se faire vraiment comme
ça dans des conditions aussi pro était
ce prix ce temps même du groupe à la
plus belle voix ça mais seules photos du
tournage que j'ai sur mon téléphone que
j'envoyais mes potes c'était la cantine
du midi parce que ouais mais parce qu'en
fait du tournage un peu comme ça de
cours à larache c'était toujours un
sandwich sur le bord et tout est là on
avait des bars même une table et des
petites serviettes et tous les gîtes
même genre puis quand on lui demande le
plus important sur un tournage
manon se fait moins enfantine le plus
important pour moi c'est leur l'humain
sur un tournage les caractères des gens
c'est quelque chose qui est très fort
sur un tournage et parfois c'est ça qui
peut perturber la technique on trouve
toujours une solution une vidéo et un
truc mais après s'habituer la fatigue et
les gens qui sont agacés et tout ça
c'est c'est
anticipé quand on n'a jamais connu c'est
vrai que ça peut être lourd pour
apprendre le tournage en ce cas quand la
nuit tombe sur la cité des arts nous
retrouvons manon pour la projection en
avant-première de la petite sirène plus
stressés
une maman
je ne sais pas
m
c'est vrai j'ai pas dormi la misère
et ce soir manon partage l'affiché avec
l'auteur acteur et metteur en scène
vincent fontano qui présente lui aussi
son premier film et qui malgré la
différence de gabarit n'en mène pas
large
le petit
cent personnes
[Musique]
la rolex cup
non mais c'est pas là
ça
pis tu vas trois ans comme ça qui sort
son premier 100 premiers films
nous faisons nous
et du haut de ses 1 m 58
manon n'a peur de rien elle savoure
juste le chemin parcouru pour venir chez
moi pour tourner alors j'étais parti à
17 ans à paris pour faire du cinéma est
en fait je reviens ici et ça ça fait bah
voilà donc merci à tous d'être venus ce
soir
alors quand les lumières s'éteignent
manon retient son souffle sur le grand
écran
c'est son rêve que l'on découvre ce soir
quelqu'un va une histoire qui fait peur
ça m'a plu 17 qu'est ce que ça change
24 minutes plus tard les
applaudissements suscite chez manon plus
d'émotion que de joie
la jeune fille sait que ce n'est que le
début de l'aventuré dans deux ans elle
espère tourner son premier long métrage
chez elle à la réunion
[Musique]